the concept of living in the moment is
one of great reverence amidst the human
spirit it speaks on behalf of the
enduring human goal to obtain control
over the swiftly escaping creature that
is time to enjoy the life we have while
we still have it around 20 BC a Roman
poet named Horus coined one of the first
recorded and recognizable versions of a
phrase related to living in the moment
the phrase being carpe diem which
translates into seize the day and ever
since this same idea of seizing the day
has been expressed in various ways as
the concept has only continued to grow
in popularity very recently it has seen
another new iteration with the rapper
Drake's acronym Yolo standing for you
only live once regardless of how it is
said the idea of living in the moment is
appealing and seductive as it offers a
way out of the senseless living patterns
that cause us to throw away our time and
neglect an appreciation of life what's
interesting though is that regardless of
its popularity over a span of 2,000
years living in the moment is still more
of a hopeful ideal than something that
most people do arguably this is because
there is an inherent conflict between
living in the moment and human nature
itself simply we want our moments in
life to be the best they can be but here
lies our problem the reason why we
struggle to ever truly seize the moment
is because we try too hard we try to
perfect the moment
instead of living in it we work to make
sure that it is worthy and refused to
accept it as it is we combat the
uncertainty of its quality with planning
and routine but in the planning process
we use up all of our moments every
moment becomes a stepping stone to the
next assuming that what we will find in
the next will exceed the previous and
with this no moment can ever exist for
itself but it is not hopeless the mere
awareness of this conflict can help us
overcome it and find our way back into
this moment we can use our need for
certainty to be certain that this moment
is sufficient more than planning each
moment requires an appreciation for what
it is and improbable and astounding
opportunity to experience life as
something that can understand the value
of a moment at all the odds of becoming
a human are one in four trillion and
every moment we can say we beat those
odds is invaluable by spotlighting our
consciousness on this thought we can
begin to live more and more in the
moment and reduce the weight of our
concern for the next living in the
moment is undoubtedly easier said than
done but it is your duty to yourself if
you are not experiencing life and
instead life is experiencing you this
moment is your only way out
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder